[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nous sommes bien
contents d'être revenus vous voir auj
vous nous manquez beaucoup tous les
jours nous nous demandait quand est-ce
que je vais revoir mes petits amis et
nicolas et pimprenelle qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent bien faire j'avais eu le cafard
pourtant les étaient mignons les petits
enfants là bas mais beaucoup moins
mobile sans que vous c'est vrai il était
moins sage patron moi je descend vite
voir nicolas et pimprenelle oui nounours
car ils attendent avec impatience
et hop bon le seul robot popopo bon
alors pour le pearl oil aux duos autre
chose dit on a mis du temps pour revenir
de voyage
oui jamais kaki et nous nous sommes
plaints géographie alors je m'étais
trompé dans mon cas c'est quoi ce truc
bizarre que tu n'auras pas c'est
l'humour non c'est un âne à un succulent
tu l'as trouvé au mexique
on n'est pas arrivés jusque là on a été
bloqué à adama viala
il y avait beaucoup de bruit à anna may
les gens très agitée qui criait je ne
sais pas pourquoi ils ont tiré avec
leurs fusils sur notre but a atteint
10,1 vapeur oui et puis le marchand de
sable rajouter plein de sable et ça les
a un peu calmé
j'adore me je pose bien alors nous avons
fait demi tour et avant jeté l'ancré
dans une charmante petite île au teaser
pour réparer notre nuage qui était comme
une passoire et si tu vois qu'il a
réparé évidemment je sais tout réparer
et c'est là tu as trouvé cette à mana
mais oui et c'est là que j'ai appris à
danser avec les jolis antillaise avec
une pointe sur la tête comme ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
pauvre nonce va oui pas trop fort
allons les enfants ou tout doux mais tu
viens demain nous alors on est bien
content et on va se coucher
[Musique]
c'est vrai tu sais tout réparer oui je
bricole alors tu pourras musée des tu
pourras bricoler on devait casser la
lumière de la salle de bain d'un jeu
vous arrange rue
j'étale
pneus online annonces à demain nikon à
un humain brunel
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit
petit pas prenait lé 28 tous les enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents et allez
vite vous couchez allons en route fidèle
compagnon faites de beaux rêves
à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
où